Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here!
You're watching. You made it.
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys, as the country
continues to deal
with the pandemic,
the director of the CDC
just said that she's aiming
to improve the agency's
COVID messaging.
Yeah, then
in her next interview,
she said the CDC is not aiming
to improve their messaging.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, in the CDC's defense,
it's hard to get any message out
when every ad on TV
is for Caesars Sportsbook.
Yep, the CDC wants
to communicate more clearly,
so going forward,
their press releases
will no longer be
in the Wingdings font.
Some more news.
I read that Neil Gorsuch
is the only
Supreme Court justice
who won't wear a mask
to help protect his colleague,
Sonia Sotomayor,
who has diabetes.
[ Audience boos ]
You know Gorsuch is the guy
who touches every bagel
before picking one.
You know that? He's like...
You guys remember Neil Gorsuch.
He used to work
for the law firm
Rogan, Hogan & Facebook.
Hey, I saw a news anchor
in Mexico who looked like
he finally hit
his breaking point
with people
who won't get vaccinated.
Check this out.
-iUstedes! [Bleep]
[ Shouting Spanish ]
[Bleep]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Yo!
You know that's how Dr. Fauci
feels on the inside.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard that today
former New York City mayor
Bill de Blasio announced
that he is not running
for Governor of New York.
He then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
He then waited over ten minutes
for someone to say, "Aw."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, de Blasio
won't run for governor.
He said he wants
to spend more time at home
being booed by his family.
Did he really
have to announce that?
I mean, he might as well
have announced that he won't be
performing at the Super Bowl
Halftime Show.
It's like, "Yeah, we know."
Some business news here.
Apparently airlines
are dealing with
the ongoing pilot shortage
by raising pay
and lowering the requirements.
[ Laughter ]
Passengers said, "That's nice."
And, "Wait. What?"
[ Laughter ]
This probably explains
why my last pilot
was wearing a Petsmart uniform.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's not very reassuring
when your pilot is the same guy
who drove your Uber
to the airport.
He's like, "Alright. Let's go.
Here we go. Come on."
[ Laughter ]
Now instead of needing
years of experience, pilots just
have to complete a CAPTCHA
that proves that they're human.
Yeah, they'll hire anyone
right now.
Here's the newest United pilot
I saw.
-[ Shouting Spanish ]
[ Applause ]
-That's a bit much.
-Geez.
-Well, speaking of flying,
a man went viral on TikTok
when he shared his experience
as the only passenger
on an eight-hour
international flight.
Somehow we have a pilot
and passenger shortage.
I don't know.
Of course, they wouldn't let him
board until his zone was called.
"Group two."
"Sorry, sir.
You're group four.
Group two. One more time."
It's weird
when the pilot's like,
"Uh, we will now be making
our approach, Tom."
Hey, this is also going viral.
Someone posted a video
of a FedEx driver
who didn't exactly deliver
their package with care.
Watch this.
-Woman in audience:
Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
His boss called him and said,
"Just a little more practice,
and you can do it without
slowing down the truck."
Respect for that aim,
though, huh?
-Yeah, that was good aim, man.
-Finally, a woman in Canada
was driving on a frozen river
when the ice broke
and her car started to sink.
And instead of panicking,
she took a selfie.
Take a look.
Don't worry. When the river
saw that it was a yellow Subaru,
it spit the car right back up.